what is it about the monster group
or the monster the sporadic monster
group that you find fascinating because
to an outsider so let's say someone
who's not interested in math
to say that it's interesting is almost
as arbitrary as saying
why are there six platonic solids or why
does the number 1740 exist
yeah um because we don't understand why
the monster exists i mean
you know so there's this classification
of the finite simple groups
and the classification says well there
are these infinite families and
okay infinite families of things are
kind of uninteresting and well
okay they're not uninteresting but most
mathematicians find them very
interesting but
um finding an infinite family of things
isn't too surprising but but the
classification says there are these
infinite families like alternating
groups and then there are
26 others left over which there's no
obvious reason why they should exist and
the
infinite families you can sort of think
of a reason why they exist i mean you
know they're they're
general linear groups and they exist
because they're symmetries of vector
spaces
it's a very natural explanation and then
you have these sporadic simple groups
exist and they exist because
well nobody really has any idea why they
exist there's
no explanation for them beyond going
through you know 10 000 pages of the
classification
so this this may be one of these
unanswerable questions like you know
what i mentioned is why does the
universe exist um
i mean maybe it just doesn't have an
answer what would an answer look like
i this is the problem i just cannot
imagine how you could even answer the
question why does the universe exist i
mean
imagine an answer that would satisfy you
as to why the monster group exists what
would that even look like
um one one thing might be that
you know that there's some very natural
class of geometric
objects whose symmetries are the
um sporadic simple groups and these
we've been searching for this for
decades and no one has ever found any
plausible candidates
so um
i mean for instance the infinite
families of groups there is a sort of
natural answer they
that they all act the the they
all have these structures called bn
pairs
and this sort of gives an explanation of
them
that there's a uniform construction of
all the
um spread of all these simple groups
that aren't sporadic
you know there's sort of one
construction that works for all of them
you just
twiddle a few parameters and you you get
out all of them but for the sporadics
there's nothing like that